you can buy not only bread and rice
but also human labor unemployed men
gather here hoping to pick up work
dw investigated why so many tajiks
leave their homes to join so-called
islamic state
what induces them to leave this former
soviet republic
and travel to places so many people are
currently fleeing
afghanistan syria and iraq
it's early in the morning
these men from the countryside have come
here to find work
of any kind
we stand here all day from six in the
morning until seven
in the evening many rent a room nearby
so they can get here early
we all have families to feed and parents
electricians and plumbers but we don't
have a job
tajikistan borders afghanistan where the
problem of jihadists has grown even
worse in recent months
with the taliban making territorial
gains
tajikistan used to be a soviet state up
until 2005
russian soldiers patrolled the border
then they left
since then more and more islamists
infiltrate the
country in the countryside people have
been signing up with insurgent groups by
the dozen
kurgan juba is a desperately poor area
not far from the border with afghanistan
there is no gas to be had
nor running water most of the men here
are unemployed
this woman's brother went to syria to
fight for is
he earned his money by killing until he
himself was killed
it was excruciating for me to find out
where he was
for the first few months i just cried i
did it in secret so my mother wouldn't
hear me
she has heart problems when she found
out where my brother was
she started having heart attacks and had
to go to hospital
i don't wish that on anybody not even my
enemies
ashamed ali still can't understand how
her brother who lived under the same
roof as her became a terrorist
she says that her brother's wife and
three children are living in is
territory in syria
asham now lives alone her mother is
still in hospital
more and more tajiks are disappearing
from villages like these
desperation and despair leads them to
join is and other groups
hoping to be able to support their
families according to official figures
just over a thousand men have left so
far the way to their new life
often lies here over the mountains to
afghanistan
behind this mountains tajikistan has a
long
largely unsecured border with
afghanistan which is a weak link in
central
asia's security smugglers drug
traffickers and religious
extremists dominate everyday life across
there
unemployment and poverty are here on
this side of the board in tajikistan
all this is a highly dangerous
combination
of used to be the highest ranking
officer in the tajik security forces and
head of security at the interior
ministry
but in the spring of last year he joined
is
in this video khamilov swears revenge on
non-religious tajiks
god willing he says i will come to your
houses with this weapon
and kill you
for banning the opposition islamic
renaissance party as a terrorist group
in a country where 90 percent of the
inhabitants are muslim
and as long as tajikistan must contend
with its dire poverty and political
conditions
its men will be easy prey to recruiters
from the islamic state
and other jihadist groups